mutlu ist auf radtour durch seinen
wahlkreis er ist abgeordnete der grünen
in berlin
erste station bürgersprechstunde im
freien gruppenfoto mit den helfern das
wird umgehend verschickt in die sozialen
medien wie facebook und in diesem fall
twitter für ihn eine chance die wähler
hierher einzuladen
viele menschen ist durch media unterwegs
sind egal ob auf facebook instagram oder
twitter kriegen mit was macht der mann
und wen auch dass ich der kandidat der
berühre barbaren in der anfangsphase
kandidat bin und das ist sehr gut
der grüne mit türkischen wurzeln muss
online aber auch viel beschimpfungen aus
haltung von rechtssystem und
ausländerfeindlichen deutschen zum
beispiel die in ihm ein hassobjekt
entdeckt haben ist dieser ganze hass der
bevölkerung früher anonym war versteckt
war
der kann viel leichter verbreitet werden
louis intensivnutzer seine smartphones
wieder sozialen medien nachbarn zum
gespräch kommen schiebt dann noch einen
termin 1
er fährt in einen anderen berliner
stadtteil hier geht es vor allem um
integration
darunter auch wähler mit türkischen
wurzeln wie mutlos selbst und auch die
beschimpfen ihn immer wieder zu stimmen
hoffentlich wird sie seine leiche an
hunde kommen nie wieder in die türkei
ich werde ich am montag bei der
staatsanwaltschaft verklagen damit zu
wenigstens bei seiner einreise in die
türkei festgenommen oder die deutsche
variante des hasses in diesem fall
vernets
es wird zeit dass auschwitz buchenwald
und andere den betrieb wieder aufnehmen
da gehört ihr dreck stück nämlich ab
durch den schornstein hier kümmel türken
und nebenbei werden sogar noch
arbeitsplätze geschaffen haben viele
politiker auch in gemeinden und städten
in deutschland anzeige erstattet weil
sie bedroht wurden mindestens einer trat
sogar zurück anzeigen scheitern oft auch
am konzern facebook der die identitäten
der verfasser nicht preisgeben will
mobbingopfer finden die politik müsse
mit einer entsprechenden gesetzgebung
eingreifen
niko härting kritisiert bisherige
versuche als zu halbherzig in die
politik hat sich er hat mich ganz ganz
verwaschen eigentlich verhalten weil sie
einerseits sagte sollte nur facebook
sollten neu strafbar auslöschen
jetzt wenn sie aber meine verurteilung
statistiken reinschauen
da wird ja so gut wie nichts verurteilt
also ist offensichtlich von dem was bei
facebook und hat viel zur anzeige
gebracht das sieht außer frage fühlt
also gibt es offensichtlich gar nicht so
viel strafbares auch von 40
strafanzeigen des abgeordneten mutloser
bislang keine erfolgreich weitere sind
anhängig
der politiker fühlt sich machtlos weil
die justiz viele kommentare als freie
meinungsäußerung betrachtet entführung
ich muss als politiker beleidigung und
bedrohung ich aushalten dass ich als
mensch öffentlichen lebens natürlich
sehr viel aushalten muss das ist klar
aber wenn ich bedroht werde wenn ich
beleidigt werde wenn meine familie
bedroht wird beleidigt wird dann hört
der spaß auf der insel politiker geht
auch das recht für politiker gilt auch
für das strafrecht so dass die geschützt
werden müssen dagegen verfolgt und
beleidigt werden suresh anmut liegt es
an facebook dass er einen seiten solche
botschaften im wahlkampf verbreiten kann
und andererseits der haft heraus
gefiltert wird
wenn facebook will könnten sie auch
algorithmen in ihr system einbauen in
die straftatbestände tatsächlich
festhalten aber das unternehmen will als
mich schon mit low wird sich nun einmal
mehr für verschärfte gesetze gegen hat
kommentare ein wetten mit den drohungen
gegen ihn muss er bis dahin alleine
zurechtkommen